Look at this skeleton.
How is it different from your skeleton?
Do you know what it is?
CLUE: This animal swims.
It's a blue whale.
It has no leg bones.
Its arms are flippers.
Whales are supported by the water.
If a whale lived on land, its skeleton would have to be much stronger.
Look at this skeleton.
How is it different from your skeleton?
Do you know what it is?
CLUE: This animal runs well.
It's a horse.
It has long legs for running.
A horse has a large rib cage to keep its large lungs safe.
It needs large lungs to take in lots of air when it runs.
Look at this skeleton.
How is it different from your skeleton?
Do you know what it is?
CLUE: This animal slithers.
It's a snake.
It has no arms or legs.
Its skeleton is one long backbone with ribs.
Look at these skulls, or head bones.
These are the skulls of the animals in this book.
Look at how their shapes and parts are different.
Each animal's skeleton is perfect for the way it lives.
It has the right kind of teeth for the food it eats.
It has the right kind of skeleton for the support it needs.
It has the right kind of skeleton for the way it moves.
And so do you.